[Music]  [Music]  named Phineas Tomas  the chaos of Wars brought a new wave of  refugees to these shores will never  accept us who will never understand us  it's time for a fresh start  don't you know do you know what Philo's  alive your police haven't charged with  finding the man responsible for these  attacks  [Music]  your lives shoes left me in the ashes of  my own life this is wearing  [Music]  Kilis Salalah she was taken by something  unnatural now  nor Fay  [Music]  she loves you and he's gonna get her  killed  they don't know the truth about you  lands no better than the pain he's  caused the people he loves whom are you  willing to do to set it right  you